[Music]
in this representation the movement of
human and divine law finds its necessity
expressed in individuals in the
universal appears as apostles and the
activity of the movement appears of the
action of individuals which gives the
appearance of contingency to the
necessity of the activity but
individuality and action constitute the
principle of individuality as such a
principle with which in its pure
universality was called inner divine law
as the moments of the visible community
its activity is not confined merely to
the underworld or to its outer existence
but it has an equally visible existence
and movement in the actual nation taking
in this form what was represented as a
simple movement of the individualized
pothos acquires a different look and the
crime and consequent destruction of the
community acquire the proper and
characteristic form of their existence
human law in its universal existence is
the community in its activity in general
as the manhood of the community it is
real and effective activity of the
government it is moves and maintains
itself by consuming and absorbing into
itself the separatism of the penalties
or the separation into independent
families presided over by womankind and
by keeping them dissolved in its fluid
continuity of its own nature but the
family is at the same time in general
its element the individual consciousness
the basis of its general activity since
the community only gets in existence
through its interference with the
happiness of the family and by
dissolving individual self-consciousness
into the universal it creates for itself
in what it suppresses and what is at the
same time essential to it an internal
enemy womankind in general womankind the
everlasting irony in the life of the
community changes by intrigue the
universal end of the government into a
private end transforms its universal
activity into a work of some particular
individual and pervert the universal
property of the state into a possession
and ornament for the family woman in
this way it turns to ridicule the
earnest wisdom of mature age which
indifferent to purely private pleasures
and enjoyments as well as to playing an
active part only cares only thinks up
and
here's four the universal she makes this
wisdom an object of derision for wrong
irresponsible youth and unworthy of
their enthusiasm in general she
maintains that it is the power of youth
that really counts the worth of the Sun
lies in his being the lord and master of
the mother who bore him that of the
brother is being one in whom the sister
finds man on a level of equality and
that of the youth is being one to remove
the daughter free from her dependence on
the family obtained the enjoyment and
dignity of life would the community
however can only maintain itself by
suppressing the spirit of individualism
and because it is an essential moment
all the same creates it and moreover
creates it by its repressive attitude
towards it as a hostile principle
however this principle being merely evil
and futile in its separation from the
universal end would be quite ineffectual
if the community itself did not
recognize the power of youth the manhood
which while immature still stands within
the sphere of individuality and the
power of the whole for the community is
a nation is itself an individuality and
essentially is only such for itself by
other individuality is being for it by
excluding them from itself and knowing
itself to be independent of them the
negative side of the community
suppressing the isolation of individuals
within it that spontaneously active in
an outward direction
finds its weapons in individuality war
is the spirit and the form in which the
essential moment of the ethical
substance the absolute freedom of the
ethical self from every existential form
is present in its actual and authentic
existence while on the one hand war
makes the individual systems of property
and personal independence as well as the
personality of the individual himself
feel the power the negative on the other
hand this negativity is prominent in war
as that which preserves the whole the
brave youth and woman finds her pleasure
the suppressed principle of corruption
now has his day and his worth is openly
acknowledged now in his physical
strength and what appears as a matter of
luck that decides on the existence of
ethical life of spiritual necessity
because of the existence of ethical life
rests on strength and lust
decision is already made that's downfall
has come just as previously only the
penitents succumb to the national spirit
so now the living spirits of the nations
have come through their own
individuality and perish in a universal
community whose simple universality is
soulless and dead and is alive only in
the single individual qua single the
ethical shape of spirit is vanished and
another takes its place
in this very lengthy paragraph number
475 we are almost at the end of this
second subsection of the first portion
of the massive spirit section of the
work
what Hegel is has been doing is working
out this dynamic between the human law
and the divine law and those who
represent both of them throughout these
two sections and now we're at the point
where we're going to see both of them
succumb and be replaced by another
understanding of law which is going to
be that worked out in in the next
section so first we have to actually get
all the way through to the debacle or
the catastrophe of this law that was
supposed to be doling out or divvying up
the ethical substance and which ended up
we saw conflicts arising not only within
you know the society itself but even in
each of these laws so Hegel says in this
representation is forced along right the
movement of human and divine law finds
it successfully expressed in individuals
we've seen this as a key idea in whom
the universal appears as a pathos and a
something that's inflicted upon them you
might say and the activity of the
movement appears as the action of
individuals and here's the big problem
which which give the appearance of
contingency to the necessity of the
activity so we've already seen this
contrast in the earlier paragraphs Hegel
had just highlighted how nature has it's
sort of cruel sway by introducing
contingency you know in the shape of the
two brothers where rulership is supposed
to be unified now he's going to talk
about this even more and Hegel is going
to do this in a way that reflects you
know gender roles as he is understanding
them and as I think he's taking them
quite a bit from their representations
in ancient Greece we might you know say
that
perhaps this is something to be itself
alcohol bin to be surpassed but but
Hegel is thinking this out in his own
time and he's going to contrast the
woman versus the the man in terms of the
the workings of these the woman is going
to be identified with nature here so he
says individuality and action constitute
the principle of individuality as such a
principle which in its pure universality
was called inner divine law and we saw
people acting on the behalf of that
divine law then he says as a moment of
the visible community if the activity is
not confined merely to the underworld or
two outer existence but has an equally
visible existence and movement in the
actual nation so the divine law now we
saw is somehow honored or taken into
account by the nation and then he says
in this form what was represented as a
simple movement of the individualized
pathos requires a different look the
crime the consequent destruction of the
community acquire the proper and
characteristic form of their existence
so what does that mean
that's what he's going to be charting
out the crime that the person motivated
by divine law going against the
community going against the government
is now going to be fully you could say
universalized so he says human law in
its universal existence is the community
right that has been the constant
throughout this entire section human law
is the community and it is for the
community it is manifest to the
community he says it's activity in
general and here we get to the gender
roles again is the manhood of the
community why is that well the community
itself is he's going to point out you
know this is not something new is
composed of families right and those
families each of them has brothers and
husbands
who leave the family at least
temporarily become part of the community
and thereby are engaging in this very
public normative work which is
essentially male-dominated and we saw
that Hegel has no problem identifying
human law with the mail and and divine
law with the female whether it be the
wife in this case or whether it be the
sister as it was in some of the other
cases so he's going to go on and say
okay human law is the community it's in
its activity in general it is the
manhood of the community in its real and
effective activity it is the the
government so the government is not the
entire manhood of the community right
the government is a generally select few
or if we're talking about something like
ancient Athens after you know the
revolts and the democracy and and you
know the giving of laws by fallen and
all that sort of stuff even then it's
still a minority it's not every man in
the community it's the property owners
those who are citizens it does not
include slaves resident aliens you know
certain other people as well even if the
franchise is quite wide we can say
something similar about ancient Rome as
well you know Rome itself goes through
all these internal social conflicts
about who actually comprises the
government and this is this can be a
contested issue we saw this discussed
just in the last paragraph in terms of
the two brothers
now what Hegel is interested in here is
not that sort of civil war he's
interested in the relationship of the
families which are essentially led or
governed by women to the larger
community and then what its implications
are for the youth so he goes on and he
says it moves is maintains itself by
consuming and absorbing into itself the
separatism of the pinna test or the
separation into independent families
presided over by women
kind and keeping them dissolved in the
fluid continuity of its own nature the
government and the community as such is
really only functional as a community
when it doesn't allow the family to have
its entire possible sway what do what do
we mean by that when the family attains
a certain amount of independent power
and it's not being directed into the
community but rather is appropriating
parts of the community or even
appropriating the government to itself
then we're going to have a problem then
we're going to have what Hegel here is
denoting as individualism he doesn't
necessarily mean the individualism of
you know what we think of as as modern
radical individualism but rather a sort
of well look everybody is in it for
their own sake so we're going to get
ours this can lead to faction when the
families are powerful enough right and
they have lots of clients and allies
within the state so he goes on and he
says the family is at the same time in
general its element the family is the
element of the community the individual
consciousness the basis of its general
activity you cannot get away in Hegel's
view from family organizations as much
of the state as much of the government
as much as the community might like to
do that and may in fact have
philosophers who spell out utopian plans
for replacing the family with other
institutions that's not going to work
and so the community has got to figure
out how it's going to relate itself to
these families now notice what he says
after this here we go
since the community only gets in
existence through its interference with
the happiness of the family and by
dissolving individual self-consciousness
into the
reversal it creates for itself in what
it suppresses and what is at the same
time essential to it an internal enemy
Hagel is not saying let's be very clear
here Hagel is not saying that women are
automatically an enemy to the state or
anything like that or that they're you
know just trouble and watch out for them
he's saying because of the action of the
community of the government in
particular in making sure that families
don't get too big and strong and
independent and provide their own sort
of locus in which meaning that would
ordinarily take place within the
community is going to happen because
they do that they create women as their
enemy they render them their enemy and
so what happens here there's a new
dynamic he says womankind the
everlasting irony in the life of the
community isn't that an interesting
thing to say women kind the everlasting
irony in the life of the community
that could be said just as well by
somebody like Simone de Beauvoir as by
you know somebody roughly a century and
some decades before her Hegel womankind
has this this because of being not part
of the universal community not being
totally acknowledged within it
not having recognition within it is
created as a or constituted as some sort
of disruptive threat so he says
womankind changes by intrigue the
universal end of the government into a
private end what are we talking about
there think of what happened in dynastic
struggles the government whoever is in
charge of the community of the human law
and its administration tends to be
whether we're talking about a monarchy
and aristocracy or even a democracy
tends to be oriented in terms of the
family units you know that famous saying
behind every you know a strongman or you
know a man of achievement lies a strong
or good woman that there's lots of
variations on this Hegel seems to think
that that's actually the case and we see
this perpetually that the you know the
because of the way gender roles are
differentiated out both in ancient
Greece and Rome and also in Hegel's own
time and his views woman is the one who
speaks up for the right of the family
the woman is the one who says wait a
second why are we doing all of this
stuff in during all of these sacrifices
if our family is not going to get some
sort of benefit out of ruling why are we
doing this if we're not going to improve
our house why are we doing this if we're
not going to say establish your son as
following in your footsteps oh great
leader and because of this woman is able
to enact in effect exercise power within
the community and the government so he
goes on and he says changes by intrigue
the universal end of the government into
a private and transforms its universal
activity into a work of some particular
universal and pervert the universal
property of the state into a possession
and ornament for the family and we can
think about this not just in terms of
women and men we could think about this
in terms of any involvement of the
family within any organization
institution community large enough to
mediate meaning that is supposed to be
greater than the family unit we can
think about how this works in all sorts
of organizations and institutions here
Hegel is interested in the political
community but we might think of all
sorts of all
turn it as well so he goes on and he
says woman in this way turns to ridicule
the earnest wisdom of mature age which
indifferent to purely private pleasures
and enjoyments as well as to playing an
active part only thinks of and cares for
the universal so the leading men the you
know senac to taste right this is what
we get sent it from the old men who make
the decisions
women make fun of them they're like they
don't actually know how to rule and who
do they favor they favor the youth the
young males who are more pliable and who
are more driven by what it is that they
don't yet have their desires who are
supposed to be embodying the universal
but are really embodying individualism
so he goes down he says she makes this
wisdom an object of derision for raw and
irresponsible youth and unworthy of
their enthusiasm Hegel is talking in
effect about a kind of social revolution
happening a social revolution in which
the youth are the Allies against the
older men of the women who run the
households that's what's what's
happening here so he goes on and he says
she maintains it's the power of youth
that really counts the worth of the son
lies and in being the Lord and mad
master of the mother who bore him that
of the brothers being wanted whom the
sister finds man on a level of equality
that of the youth is being won through
whom the daughter freed from her
dependence on the family it obtains the
enjoyment and dignity of wifehood so the
youth is somebody who can be in effect
used to promote the status of women
whether the youth realizes it or not and
here Hegel says the community there's a
counter response the community can only
maintain itself by suppressing this
spirit of individualism and because it
is an essential moment all the same
creates it very interesting point there
right the more that the community tamps
down
on this the less it's able to
successfully control it it's sort of
like playing whack-a-mole if you're not
familiar with this game it's something
that you see at American theme parks and
carnivals and and you know places where
games are played and it consistent you
have a mallet and you're supposed to
whack them all and there's a lot of
different hold so it comes up out of
this hole and you hit it you push it
down there and then it pops up over
there you putt you hit it there pops up
over there keeps going and going and
going you can never actually get it
completely repressed and Hegel is
detailing exactly this sort of dynamic
on the part of the community and the
government so he says creates by its
repressive attitude towards it is a
hostile principle and this principle he
says being merely evil and futile and
separation would be ineffectual if the
community did not recognize the value of
the youth now what is the youth truly
valuable for this is again where we get
to talking about revolutions revolutions
are changes radical changes in things
Hegel's going to talk about war here why
did the youth want war why are they
directed to war is that that they are
naturally you know driven by passion or
spirit or thumos or something like that
you know the way that some ancient
Greeks have have portrayed it not all
youths are some are some aren't is it
that they see war as an opportunity to
aggrandize their own power their
prestige their wealth at the expense of
others that's not enough either Hegel
goes on and he says the youth is
recognized
right as immature but as manhood as the
power of the whole and he says for the
community is a nation is itself
individuality and essentially is only
such for itself by other individuality
z-- being for it by excluding them from
itself and knowing itself to be
independent of them so the negative side
of the community suppressing the
isolation of individuals within it but
spontaneously active in outward
direction finds its weapons and
individuality and then Hegel comes to
the point of saying war is the spirit
and the form in which the essential
moments of the ethical substance the
absolute freedom of the ethical self
from every active essential form is
present in its actual and authentic
existence what does that sound like if
you think back to previous sections of
the phenomenology doesn't that sound an
awful lot like what was happening in the
very beginnings of the
self-consciousness section the conflict
the struggle to the death it shows this
is how the community shows itself to be
absolutely free in its ethical self from
every existential form from every
determinate conditioned form from any
particular life who is capable of doing
that the old men know it is the youth
who can run into the breach who can see
danger and run towards it who can
further the nation and and its spirit so
he says while on the one hand war makes
the individual systems of property and
personal independence and as well as the
personality of the individual themself
feel the power the negative why is that
well because war throws all those things
into the balance if you live on the
marches a March is a land that borders
where the enemy are and the war is
declared you may lose your individual
home you may lose your property you may
lose your life so there's that that
negative side to it right throws all
those things into suspension into the
possibility of being lost he goes on and
he says on the other hand this
negativity is prominent
in war is that which preserves the whole
when you go to war whether whether this
is really just ideology or you know a
trickery on the part of the government
or the ruling class is there something
like that when you do go to war as a
community there is the sense that you're
belonging to something greater than
yourself something transcendent and that
by going out and fighting and risking
your life and your property and your
status and all these other things you
are becoming the universal the one who
stands in the face of the danger to the
community and who represent the
community we do this in a somewhat you
know sublimated fashion with with
certain sporting events don't we the
Haegele goes on and he says the brave
youth in whom woman finds her pleasure
the suppressed principle of corruption
right when the family takes over the
government now he has his day and his
worth is openly acknowledged now it is
physical strength and what appears as a
matter of luck that decides the
existence of ethical life and spiritual
necessity now notice this lead this is
not a triumph in many respects this is
not a triumph for the ethical why not
because the ethical is supposed to have
a different sort of necessity a decimal
speech is contingent on luck or sheer
physical strength or youthfulness or
anything like that the ethical is
supposed to be transcendent to that but
what happens instead he says because the
existence of ethical life rests on
strength and lock the decision is
already made that its downfall has come
once the ethical life of the community
depends on the the youth at war promoted
by the family promoted by women against
the you know the older men and whatever
wisdom they happen to those and then
Agel suggests is the case here things
have taken a decisive turn
and you don't get to walk back from that
so he says just as previously only the
penetrates to come to the national
spirit so now the living spirits of the
nations have come through their own
individuality and perish in a universal
community whose simple universal
universality is solace and debt is alive
only in the single individual who's the
single individual the ruler the one who
decide things neither the human law nor
the divine law is being respected in
this or furthered they're both being
sacrificed to something else so he says
he concludes here by saying the ethical
shape of spirit has vanished and another
has taken its place so what is that
other that's what remains to be seen now
this ruin of the ethical substance that
its passage into another form is thus
determined by the fact that the ethical
consciousness is directed on to the law
in a way that is essentially immediate
this determination of immediacy means
that nature as such enters into the
ethical act the reality of which simply
reveals the contradiction and the germ
of destruction inherent in the beautiful
harmony and tranquil equi Librium of the
ethical spirit itself for this immediacy
of the contradictory meaning of being
the unconscious tranquility of nature
and also the self-conscious Restless
tranquility of spirit unaccounted this
natural aspect this ethical nation is in
general and individuality determined by
nature and therefore limited and thus
meets its downfall at the hands of
another but with the vanishing of this
determinant is which in the form of a
real existence of the limitation but
equally the negative element in general
and the self of the individuality the
life of spirit in this substance which
is self conscious and everyone is lost
the substance emerges of the formal
universality and them no longer dwelling
in them as a living spirit on the
contrary the simple compactness of their
individuality has been shattered into a
multitude of separate atoms
Hegel and this long dynamic that we've
been charting out in the last two
subsections of this very first portion
of spirit by talking about the ruin of
ethical substance what is an ethical
substance giving way to that's that the
question that we have here and how does
it happen
well we've charted that out and we've
seen as long dynamic between human law
and divine law its representatives all
of that sort of stuff happening in terms
of the interplay of what Hegel is called
ethical spirit so he says this passage
into another form is determined by the
fact that the ethical consciousness is
directed on to the law in a way that's
essentially immediate what is this end
point where the law is going to be
immediate well there's going to be a
loss of the ethical substance a loss of
the kind of community in which each
person could find himself or even
herself although we saw that Hegel has
is very rather rigid conception of
gender roles within the community and
its relationship to the family so he
says that this determination of
immediacy means that nature as such
enters into the ethical act the reality
of which simply reveals the
contradiction and germ of destruction
inherent in the ethical spirit itself
and we saw that this this is going to be
you know there's going to be a
disharmony between the human law and the
divine law Hegel will go on and say on
account of this natural aspect the
ethical nation is in general an
individuality determined by nature and
therefore limited so over here on the
board I have something different than
this but what we could have here is sort
of a preliminary state where now the
nation is ruled by one person by one
self-consciousness whoever that happens
to be and that happens to be a matter of
nature which means contingency
for Hegel there's no longer the kind of
equilibrium and every person and portion
getting its role it's part it's its
function within the larger totality
that's all broken up and instead Hegel
says not only is it the case that
there's going to be somebody who
probably shouldn't be in charge by the
old way of looking at things in charge
it's not even going to be somebody from
that community he says it meets its
downfall at the hands of another another
nation or it could be somebody coming in
and taking over from the outside so he
says with the vanishing of this
determinant nacinda form of a real
existence of the limitation but equally
the negative element in general and the
self of the individuality the life of
spirit of this substance which is self
conscious and everyone is lost the
connection is sundered between people as
members of this community what connect
them the fact of being ruled by somebody
being subject so he says the substance
emerges as a formal universality in them
no longer dwelling in them as a living
spirit formal means that it's just
applying to everybody in the same way
regardless of who they are not taking
account of any of their history or
culture or status or relations with each
other just applying to everybody more or
less the same
he says I'm a country the simple
compactness of their individuality has
been shattered into a multitude of
separate atoms this is a great way to
end it here when we talk about the
atomization of individualism right what
we're talking about is everyone being
split into their own little universe
that is somehow still all being
connected up together and none of them
have any necessary relation with each
other anymore as was the case
over here so what is going to be coming
on the scene here Hegel is going to tell
us about another kind of law and that's
what happens in the section to come